so here's something in the UK they are
now writing letters to Tehran being
taught to respect terrorists of the new
teaching age so they actually wrote
about this from Mexico UK I hate that
they have to have those URLs a new
teaching aid that recommends school
children as young as seven write a
letter to a terrorist to help understand
their motives has been condemned a
dangerous and misguided really do you
think a book in question is called
talking about terrorism responding to
children's questions now it tells
primary aged children that terrorists
killed people because they believe that
they are mistreated or unfairly or not
shown respect so they want to teach kids
to sit as opposed to like writing
letters to Santa you're writing letters
to the serial rapist death in them in
the mountains of Syria this book
actually gives examples of terrorists
whose ideas then turn out to be right so
that a quote is actually the
suffragettes use violence and recalled
terrorists in this curriculum because
that's the same yes exactly so they are
in the UK writing letters to terrorists
so I mean how about instead of learning
to respect terrorists you teach kids to
despise them and take a big steaming
crap on everything that makes them tears
namely their faith their laws their
customs their address all I'd be much
more okay with raising a bunch of kids
who despise anyone who even resembles a
member of Isis than learning to respect
terrorists now there's some people that
just don't we should not sympathize with
no terrace I would highly there's Harry
Trivium Myers that even Hitler black
relatives family that's a bit sixteen I
don't want to miss I don't want the
relic exact you see interviewing people
in cages nine animal that's not so me
comparing them to suffragettes
encouraging kids to write letters to
terrorists in the UK all in the name of
multiculturalism and progress what could
possibly go wrong there okay class so
before we send our letters today we'll
be learning about ten Eva terrorists
okay now ten e the terrorists fights for
I says can everyone say I said is ice
all right no no we don't call it that
anymore
Isis is the Islamic State of Iraq and
Syria now what is Isis do in their
homeland with people who are different
from them it's a part of their culture
what have isis do they burn memo live in
cages
Oh bee burn them alive in cages well
look at that isn't that a pretty orange
look at that bright own ah what is it
important that we do when we see Isis
burning people alive in cages what's it
most important we not do it's most
important that we not judge that's right
see we're not supposed to judge
terrorists but respect but wasn't that
huh okay Bobby you can going down to the
principal now and tell them about your
intolerance that's it not a lot I don't
want to hear it go okay and just for
that remember when we're sending out
these letters we put down Bobby's return
address latest video subscribe by
clicking the subscribe button it's a kid
sedessa circle now it used to be a
square which most buttons aren't squares
let's that's on a phone they're square
buttons on phones what most buttons are
circles you understand what I'm talking
about or watch the recommended video
which is popping up in a box or
subscribe at lateral clutter comm slash
mug Club join the mug Club so you can
get the daily show and that means that
you are not beholden to the YouTube
censoring overlords so let's be honest
you like being there where you are under
their thumb power bottom you